imaginez en france on a frôlé les 40 6
degrés au thermomètre
hier en journée et bien 6e journée de
canicule pour aujourd'hui
c'est donc beaucoup plus chaud avec en
2003 lors de l'épisode de chaleur qui a
entraîné la mort de quinze mille
personnes
depuis la france a développé toute une
expertise dont on veut s'inspirer ici à
montréal notamment edward williams
d'abba ancien directeur général de la
santé en france est avec nous pour en
parler à ce matin dr nat bonjour je vous
remercie de nous parler ce matin en
direct concept sixième journée de
canicule
paris d'ailleurs qui va connaître sa
journée la plus chaude de la semaine
comment se déroule la gestion de crise
chez vous actuellement écoutez c'est ce
que je sais pas si on peut parler de
crise mais la situation est totalement
exceptionnel elle est exceptionnelle par
sa précocité
on est encore au mois de juin par son
étendue géographique c'est la quasi
totalité du pays qui est qui est touchée
de tout particulièrement le sud mais
tout le pays
et puis comme vous le mentionnez à
l'instant les records de températures
ont été battus eh bien vous malgré cette
situation je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler de crise dans le pays a au
contraire une mobilisation très positive
je dirais même très militants de tous
les services publics évidemment pompiers
services d'urgence exécuta mais au-delà
de ça et c'est surtout ça qui est
important de l'ensemble de la population
qui veille sur ses voisins qui veille
sur les personnes âgées et qui
s'organise dans un réseau de solidarité
qui je dois dire est très impressionnant
c'est rassurant vous entendre comme ça
de terre dame je pense par exemple aux
canadiens qui peuvent avoir de la
famille en france ça peut être
inquiétant quand même quand on voit ces
températures à la hausse à ce point là
vous étiez au front vous en 2003
lorsqu'il ya eu ces milliers de
personnes qui ont perdu la vie
il ya des le sang qui ont été tirées de
cet épisode là moi je j'ai pris le poste
de directeur général de la santé au
lendemain de la canicule et bien sûr la
mission que j'ai reçues et de développer
qui n'existait pas à l'époque c'est à
dire une préparation aux situations
d'urgence
pas seulement les canicules mais les
pandémies grippales et cetera évidemment
compte tenu de du terrible bilan de 2003
la canicule dont on savait déjà qu'elle
serait plus fréquentes et plus graves a
suscité une énorme préparation et là on
s'est aperçu que la clé de la prévention
c'était d'être capable d'intervenir au
domicile des gens alors que la grande
erreur de 2003 avait été de faire de la
canicule un problème hospitalier et
quand les gens arrivent à l'hôpital
c'est beaucoup trop tard et le taux de
mortalité va être très élevé alors si
des canadiens ont de la famille à paris
oui
rapprochez-vous 2 est le principal
conseil alors 2 2 principaux conseils
il faut voir au moins deux vitres et
demie par jour même quand on a pas soit
parce que l'autre particularité de cette
canicule c'est qu'elle est arrivée après
un printemps médiocre et que les
organismes
nous menons ne se sont pas préparés à
cette hausse brutale de température on a
gagné 20 degrés en trois jours c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment beau c'est
incroyable précoce pendant la saison le
contenu l'été commence à peine donc vous
êtes premier conseil les gens doivent
voir qu'elle soit fou non delettrez et
demi d'eau et vous allez enchaîner avec
un autre conseil est alors dans les
départements qui sont classées rouge
rouge dans notre plan canicule ça veut
dire que toutes les personnes sont
vulnérables
voilà alors que orange ça veut dire que
seules les personnes fragiles parce
qu'elles sont très âgées parce qu'elle
porte des maladies chroniques doivent
faire l'objet d'une vigilance
alors au delà pour ceux qui ont de la
famille dans ce département le outre
l'hydratation le principal conseil c'est
assurez vous que quelqu'un est capable
de prendre des nouvelles de votre
famille ou de vos amis
deux fois par jour le matin et le soir
et d'être capable de rentrer chez eux si
ça ne répond pas c'est cette mesure là
qui va sauver les vies donc il ya toute
une cartographie qui est faite de la
france avec un code de couleurs vous
avez parlé du rouget et du orange
vous avez dit également que c'est le
travail de terrain qui fait la
différence
s'assurer que les gens puissent avoir de
de la visite est également en terminant
de terreau d'hab y'a un registre
d'inscription volontaire ça aussi ça
fait partie du succès et ça on veut sans
espérer ici à montréal
bah écoutez je peux vous dire pour avoir
été formé en santé communautaire chez
vous que moi je me suis beaucoup inspiré
de votre expérience alors si on retour
notre expérience peut vous servir les
bajans serait effectivement très très
satisfait mais vous avez un réseau de
santé public qui est très performant on
l'a vu il ya dix ans au moment de la de
la canicule je pense que vous êtes bien
armé au faire face à des situations
exceptionnelles mais évidemment que si
on peut vous aider
on le fera très fraternellement c'est
gentil donc vous l'avez mentionné vous
avez étudié
ici je crois à l'université laval à
québec cet examen peut tout à fait comme
à résidence dans son thé communautaire à
l'université laval
c'est un échange d'expertisé qu'on fait
auquel on assiste actuellement docteur
william dab
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous